sichtlich erschrocken hin dass das ende
der arena erreicht auch so
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde ender gamescom
hd punkt nett ich hab jetzt jemand
schutzschild optimiert weil die alle
hier so ein bisschen so rum grabl nicht
schreibt hey mach jetzt mal eben das
schutzschild aus ich habe noch nie
ändern games gebracht habe es gestern
mal kurz mit max angespielt und es macht
mir echt spaß ich kann zwar noch nicht
alle regeln und dies das anders aber
deswegen habe ich euch ja dass eventuell
ein kommentar ist was sich eventuell
noch falsch mache es geht halt darum
dass man ja ihr werdet schon sehen wie
es funktioniert denke ich ich gehe
einfach eine lobby und zwar erst mal
haben wir ein paar leute gesagt
geheimnisvolles geräusch ist dass ich
dachte jetzt ok ich muss nicht auflösen
weil es war klar das ist ein crash love
letter word ist in der flatrate aufnahme
aber was sie geschrieben würden endpoint
dlp das geräusch ist ich schätze bei dem
spielplatz live wenn man online gegen
andere spieler kämpfen will dann kommt
immer so ein geräusch was das video the
bird und ich mache das sind dann oder
eine peitsche von einer iphone app die
buttons heißt dass sie keine ahnung hat
man da findet aber nie gewonnen hat lpkf
lippi wird wenn er sich richtig richtig
doll auf die eier legt und das richtig
weh tut also da hat peking und das jetzt
jetzige geräuschen könnte ihm ein
schutzschild ich könnte mir kommt aber
schreibe was richtig geiles was denke
ich auch ich wenig rauskriegen werden
und zwar hört mal genau zu dass hier
ich mach's noch einmal diesmal was denkt
ihr ist das für ein geräusch schreibt in
die kommentare eventuell ist es eure
kommentare judith mal weg hier ist dass
spender gay games ich nehme
selbstverständlich höhe lassen hier muss
schluss macht das spiel gilt schon lief
lief schnell raus gekommen hier direkt
direkt los
doch jetzt und zwar nehme ich den vampir
einfach mal als mp wirst du durch das
töten von gegnerischen spielern komplett
und für jeden getöteten ob mit drei
herzen geheilt nutze diese fähigkeit und
seinem kampf überraschend schnell wieder
regeneriert und kampfbereit finde ich
ist das geil zitiert ich habe die ganze
premium kitze noch nicht weil ja nicht
so viele punkte wie oben nehme ich
einfach mal savannah lassen es ist cool
und nick nahe kommt doch jetzt heißt ich
bunkern
so also ich bin jetzt der vampir datei
ist falls du das jetzt nicht verstanden
hab ich werde es ist wie survival games
am anfang es gibt kisten die stars an
alle möglichen sachen drin und danach
treten überall in der welt doch tauchen
so ender kisten auf also überall und die
sache ist halt wenn ich zum beispiel
geboxt werde und ich hab dann nur noch
zwei herzen und ich laufe von jemandem
weg und ich habe zum beispiel die
schwert aber ich weiß nicht verpackter
laufe ich einfach weg weil ich in der
nähe zum beispiel ein paar hütchen sehe
schlage zum beispiel wenn ich einen
hübschen schlage ist es ja mit dem dia
schwer direkt tot
das heißt ich bekommen drei herzen dazu
das hat mich 13 hab ich dann sechs herz
natürlich noch münchen habe ich noch
kann ich direkt wieder mich umdrehen
denn an boxen welchen anderen töten und
ich zum beispiel noch ein herz hat und
die töte den anderen habe ich wieder
komplett leben also vampir finde ich die
beste klasse ich weiß nicht ob das ist
eher premium kehrt ja das sind starter
kit hier diese vier und den rest kann
man sich halt kaufen
und ja sonst würde ich eigentlich weiß
nicht super mario als auch ganz cool an
weil er halt direkt so sachen hat und
das coole an
ender games ist halt auch dass du alles
abbauen kannst das ist megageil
also komme hd punkt netz können einfach
mal spielen und ihr kleines folgen die
kommentare schreiben
wer es kaum kraft da ich bin bunt kam
und kommt bin ich er ist nicht da er ist
nicht mehr genau ist nicht aber ich
würde sagen wir können wieder mit euren
themen beschäftigen was hätte ich denn
hier was für eine fernsehsendung ist
seine lieblingssendung von kuki gaming
wieder auf twitter.com search von
crafter könnte mir folgen und dann dies
dass der eigentlich zu den ganz einfach
laufen beim eine lieblingssendungen war
sehr sehr lange zeit jetzt bis jetzt
immer noch ich gucke sehr wenig serien
breaking bad orb ich mag es geht los
bisschen konzentrieren aber sonst hat
man okay ich habe viel eisen ich habe
auf jeden fall lesenswert schon mal das
ganz gut
oha wasserdampf in dem ort alter achso
mit einer axt man das dann direkt ab ich
weiß nicht keine ahnung ich brauche auf
jeden fall eine rüstung diesmal das
heißt mehr eisen und soll ich werde
wahrscheinlich erst mal ein bisschen
laufen dass sich ein paar sachen habe so
also
breaking bad war lange zeit meine
lieblingsserie dann war es halt vorbei
ja weil es halt einfach vorbei war diese
hat halt nur fünf staffeln ist sehr sehr
wenig finde ich da hätte man noch so
viel mehr rausholen können aber die
serie ist so geil ich liebe diese ich
lieber ein paar brötchen wetters ist
richtig richtig cool finde ich und ja
man da machen wir doch gleich eine
diamant kacke natürlich die wichtige
beleben und so schön hamburger brommer
feine oder sonst braking bag will die
echt sagen ist zu meiner lieblingsserie
mehr fällt mir als auch nicht an was wir
auch eine spitzhacke machen wir eben
hier für eine rüstung und so bisschen
leder sonst gucke ich ab und zu mal big
bang theory rein aber jetzt nicht so
dass ich jetzt sage ok cherie läuft muss
ich schnell nach hause so so nicht halt
so dann einfach so wenn es läuft und
halt immer irgendwie sonntagsmorgens ich
weiß nicht sonntags monster samstags
morgens aber auf jeden fall immer wenn
ich den tag davor irgendwie feiern war
oder sich am nächsten tag einfach scrubs
morgens da mach ich mir ein schönes und
dann schön spox dabei gucken und dabei
schön und frühstücken finde ich es
megageil und da damit auch schon den
ersten kuss kann nämlich sein dass wir
jetzt jeden moment gewartet werden das
heißt es kann sein dass mein platz wo
ich gerade bin
mit einer person getauscht wird die
irgendwo am arsch der welt ist aber dass
ja geil ich habe echt relativ coole
sachen hier
vier eisen da können wir nichts machen
da hinten sehe ich ein spieler steht am
ammersee jetzt wirklich getäuscht es
geht also immer wenn man getauscht wird
am besten einfach rennen weil es kann
sein dass halt direkt neben einer ist
man kann auf den kompass rechtsklick
drücken und jetzt sehe ich die anderen
50 blöcke von mir weg 740 das heißt wir
laufen uns quasi aufeinander zu da ist
der toni schwerte scheiße okay ich bin
am ende war ich zu gut
das skelett in bogen und jag den winter
auch noch umbringen wahrscheinlich
obwohl diesen relativ gleich ausgerüstet
jetzt ist er tot
wo aber der hat echt geile sachen aber
ich würde gerne direkt hier noch was
dran hängen hier direkt rein hier wieder
vampir ja nämlich und dann spielen wir
mal patch vor er sei ja ganz gut
so saßen wir da madeira 23 kommt erst
like a 10 kann ich nicht gerade
ich muss auch gleich mit käfer aufnehmen
das heißt diese folge kann höchstens
sechs minuten dauern weil ich damit
kämpfen durchdacht jetzt damit die heute
wenigstens ein zweites video habt also
ja dass meine lieblingssendung
wie würdest du es finden wenn du andere
youtuber tagen in der juden müsstest du
würdest von tv hd finde ich ist eine
gute frage jetzt kommen immer mehr geile
fragen an das ist richtig richtig gut
von euch die daumen hoch hier an die
community von euch von mir und zwar weiß
ich nicht es kommen so viele geile
fragen mittlerweile an diesen
richtigkeit wo man richtig lange drüber
diskutieren kann
ich mag interview sehr sehr gerne ich
ich wird richtig gern so interviews
führen so leute interviewen so auch so
aber so schoss damit mäßig so ein
bisschen so zirkus halligalli eine coole
sendung die ich sehr gerne schauen dass
man da halt einfach leute einlädt mit
dem so einfach quatsch dies dass ananas
und so und los geht's
ok einfach fast nur scheiß bekommen
beste leben
so was haben sie sonst noch so
wir wollen natürlich erst mal ein
schwert ich das auch euch gleich dann
mal eventuell demonstrieren können an
diesem schwein was meine klasse nämlich
so ausmacht
ich hab nur 30 sekunden sowie das gut
ich kann mir eine spitzhacke machen so
und eine spitzhacke nämlich damit
natürlich hätten sich shia online
erklärte sie der pci weg des todes
gerade
so habe ich mich erschrocken was war
denn das das ende der arena erreicht
auch so gerade des todes erschrocken
einfach mal pizza bestimmt noch
wasserstoff h einfach mal das ende der
arena erreichte ich habe mich so
erschrocken ohne spaß als wenn da
irgendwie was unsichtbares auf mich
zugekommen wäre habe ich eigentlich
weile nicht mehr fall aber ich konnte
mir das kann es nicht sein das kann doch
nicht wahr sein
da wollte ich mir gerade so schwer
machen wo ich hätte ich so geboxt mann
du verdammt nein ich nehme dort auf man
ärgerlich so was und dann kann man noch
immer wenn ich aufnehme wichtige klopfte
kacke sowas ist man so was ein wenig
respekt ihren kern so egal ich hoffe wir
können ja noch mal eben schnell ganz
schnell hier nach wie gesagt ich bin ja
noch nicht so der allerbeste drin war ja
schon gesagt so stimmt teilnehmer mal
hier plans ab was los hier gar nichts
mehr nehmen war das spiel beginnt schon
fünf sekunden ja gut perfekt da können
wir direkt schon hier wurde schon
angeschrieben
so ich schreibe 45 minuten kanal jetzt
über dem halo so 30 sekunden hätte
wenigstens ein bisschen was dran hier
finde ich ganz cool eigentlich so leute
interviewen was würdest du davon halten
wenn die städte wieder zusammen kommen
also nur statt rot blau und gelb nichts
anderes als eine stadt pink ihre
werkstatt pink wird dann einfach keine
folgender hochladen weil die einfach so
oft verrecken würden dass es gar nicht
mehr möglich wäre dass der engelhart
hochladen
ich habe viel eisen dass es schon mal
relativ gut wo sind denn die kisten
kästen kisten kästen kisten entwendet
okay das ganz geil so hier noch im 2d
von eckbällen internen gebe ich mir eben
die erfahrung ich weiß nich bringt das
eigentlich mehr wie ich ist eine luft
schmeißen des meininger als dass man
hier gemacht habe ich glaube das
eigentlich nicht vorstellen aber gut so
dann ist man direkt hier ein schwert
machen und den brustpanzer kai niemann
aber eine hose dann kann ich mir auch
noch mal machen nämlich der thema mit do
15 sekunden noch mensch ich brauche
allerdings eine rüstung aber gut hier
sind wenigstens schicken ihn an er das
heißt da kann ich mir dann da nicht die
schutzzeit ist zu ende wie ist der
nächste an mir dran 18 blöcke 16 wie
kommt der nähe 14
ich will kein team mit euch machen ja
okay ich mache team
ich glaube die eine wollte auch kein
team machen
jetzt kommt mir jetzt nicht um jetzt
sind hier so ganz viele die jetzt so ich
werde dich gar kein team machen mit dem
eigentlich mag ich team im pvp nicht
oder gib mir sachen hey ich gebe mein
stark mache die waren so was habe ich
sonst noch so achten habe ich meinen
strom jetzt hier der nächste adc die
kita mir der typ ich wohl getäuscht wird
getratscht wird getauscht wird getauscht
wird getauscht aluh ist doch toll wenn
ich jetzt im sattel hätte ich kann mir
glaube ich kann sogar ein crafting
glaube ich hier ist ja keiner klasse die
am arsch der welt ihr ballon
entschuldigung ich ziehe jemand aber das
ist natürlich der reich wären welche
lieblingsfarbe hast du ich hab ich denn
die ist weg oder hände seiner
aber sterben kurzer folge gruppen ist
nix tolles drin vielleicht hätte ich mir
die pfeile mit ihm sollen
nein verdammt pizza machen die team-
oder ein verzaubertes die erschwert wie
kann er den verzaubert haben
oha naja gut meine lieben freunde ich
muss jetzt mit käfer aufnehmen ich bin
nicht so dramatisch nicht der allerbeste
hier drin aber ich will einfach mal
sagen es euch gefallen hat könnt ihr
trotzdem der bewertung dalassen themen
und so werden immer von twitter genommen
und sonst würde ich sagen geräusch
können kommentare schreiben wenn ihr es
hier nenne ich mach's nochmal so
schreibt zudem kommentare wenn das kennt
und dann bis 2